Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, episode. Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，那么请收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是Marianne Trent博士。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. If you are listening on the day of release, which is Monday the 29th of August 2022, and you're in the UK, then today is a bank holiday, so enjoy. Does that mean that you get to stay in bed for a bit longer? Does that mean that you get to go and do something fun? Probably not in the sun. It is, it has been very sunny lately, but today it has started pouring with rain so there may not be sun around on that day but what does it mean for you when you get an extra bank holiday? I remember when I was growing up and I used to really like shopping, my friend and I were like what is the point in bank holidays because the shops at that time were not open. We were like,
嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。如果你是在2022年8月29日星期一节目发布当天收听，且身处英国，那么今天就是银行假日（Bank Holiday），好好享受吧。这意味着你可以多睡一会儿吗？意味着你可以去做些有趣的事情吗？可能没法在阳光下享受了。最近天气一直很好，但今天开始下大雨了，所以那天可能没太阳。但多出一个银行假日对你来说意味着什么呢？我记得小时候我很喜欢逛街，我和朋友当时就在想，银行假日有什么意义呢？因为那时候商店都不开门。我们当时觉得，
we don't get it. So boring. Can't wait for the bank holiday to be over. And then once you start working, you're like, oh, okay, I get the point of the bank holidays now. I'm really sorry to all the bank holiday gods. I didn't get the point of you before because now it's about a bit of rest and recharge. You know know I think for me they really came into their own before I had children and when I was working full-time certainly when it's during the school holidays you don't really feel the benefit um certainly I don't because I usually have a Monday and a Friday off during the school holidays anyway so it's just a day, an extra day with the kids, which I know is a really nice thing as well. Okay, so if you are listening live or live-ish, then what you might well be aware of already
我们完全不懂。太无聊了，真希望银行假日快点结束。但当你开始工作后，你就会想，哦，原来如此，我现在明白银行假日的意义了。我向所有银行假日之神道歉，我以前没理解你们的意义，因为现在对我来说，这就是休息和充电的时间。你知道，我觉得对我而言，在有孩子之前，当我全职工作时，这些假期才真正发挥了作用。当然，在学校假期期间，你并不会真正感受到它的好处，嗯，至少我不会，因为在学校假期里我通常周一和周五本来就休息，所以这只是多了一天和孩子们在一起的时间，我知道这也是一件非常美好的事情。好了，如果你是在直播或接近直播的时间收听，那么你可能已经意识到，
is that we have the 1st of September on the horizon. And the 1st of September is a pretty key date for aspiring psychologists. And in case you don't know, I'll tell you why. So for a long time now, the 1st of September has heralded the opening of the application process for the clearinghouse applications for aspiring trainee clinical psychologists. So the rough timeframe is it opens for applications in September, on the 1st of September. When I was applying, it was always open until the start of December. But I know during the pandemic, they scaled it back and sort of made it mid-November. They've made it a bit earlier. I think that was to give them more time to sort out the processes involved in interviews.
9月1日即将来临。对于有抱负的心理学家来说，9月1日是一个非常关键的日期。如果你不知道原因，我会告诉你。长期以来，9月1日标志着有抱负的临床心理学实习生申请清算所（Clearinghouse）流程的开始。大致的时间框架是，申请在9月1日开放。我申请的时候，它一直开放到12月初。但我知道在疫情期间，他们缩短了时间，大概到了11月中旬。他们提前了一些，我想这是为了给他们更多时间来处理面试相关的流程。
So if you are applying, please do check what the deadlines are. I did just have a little look online to see if there was any insider info ahead of the 1st of September. And actually the Clearinghouse Leeds website says that they're getting a brand new website from September and that you can't get the new website address until September. So my advice to you would be to give it a Google Clearinghouse Leeds and I would definitely think there'll be a redirect of their website address on their current website. So the address is in the show notes but just loosely speaking, it's www.leeds.ac.uk forward slash Charlie Hotel Papa, Charlie, Charlie Papa. And that should hopefully bring you roughly to the right area. But like I said,
所以如果你正在申请，请务必查看截止日期。我刚才在网上查了一下，看看9月1日前有没有什么内部消息。实际上，利兹清算所（Clearinghouse Leeds）网站显示，他们从9月起将启用一个全新的网站，而且在9月之前无法获得新网址。所以我的建议是去谷歌搜索“Clearinghouse Leeds”，我肯定他们会在当前网站上设置重定向。地址在节目说明里，但简单来说，网址是 www.leeds.ac.uk/chc，希望这能带你找到大致的区域。但就像我说的，
if you give it a Google, it should come up and there might well be that new website address from September onwards. So I know we do have a pretty varied audience for this podcast. So we do of course have people who are wanting to apply to the doctorate in clinical psychology this year, but we also have people who don't study psychology and probably won't ever study psychology, but just enjoy learning a bit more about mental health mental health professionals and the nuts and bolts behind the scenes in creating and maintaining mental health services so let me just go over a little bit about what the processes are and what this application is all about so there are essential criteria criteria for applying for the doctorate schemes which
如果你去谷歌搜索，它应该会出现，而且从9月开始可能就会有那个新网址了。我知道我们这个播客的听众非常多样化。当然，我们有今年想申请临床心理学博士学位的人，但也有一些不学习心理学、可能永远也不会学习心理学的人，他们只是喜欢更多地了解心理健康、心理健康专业人士，以及创建和维护心理健康服务背后的细节。所以，让我简单介绍一下这些流程以及这个申请到底是怎么回事。申请博士项目有基本标准，
as a broad brush approach are largely funded courses. So you get funded by the local health education authority and employed by a local employing trust. That's certainly the case in England and I know that Scotland also offers funded places as do Wales but they aren't funded by Health Education England because they are not in England. If you're wanting to apply and you don't live in England there are options in other United Kingdom countries and there are also some self-funded places available too for some of the courses in England but the details of the amounts as of last year are in the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and it is quite expensive I think from memory it's about 30 grand a year plus of course you'd need to be able to have
总的来说，这些课程大部分是有资助的。你由当地健康教育机构资助，并受雇于当地的雇佣信托机构。在英格兰确实如此，我知道苏格兰也提供资助名额，威尔士也是，但它们不是由英格兰健康教育局（Health Education England）资助的，因为它们不在英格兰。如果你想申请但不住在英格兰，英国其他国家也有选择，英格兰的一些课程也提供自费名额。关于去年费用的详细信息在《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书中，我觉得挺贵的，记忆中大约是每年3万英镑，当然你还需要有
some way to sustain yourself to be able to pay for your rent and your living fees as well food and travel and all of that so it's not it's not a small expense if you're looking to self fund that but some organizations do fund that for their employees as well so it's not always people coming from different countries to do self-funding it is possible to be self-funded via companies sponsoring you to do that as well which is worth bearing in mind so in the most part people will be will have a right to work in the UK and may well be British citizens already and will be applying for for training for the doctoral schemes to be funded by the NHS so so I'm going to be giving that as the main advice in this podcast but if you've got circumstances outside of this, then, you know, just let me know or, yeah, give it a
某种方式来维持自己的生活，支付房租、生活费、食物和交通等。所以如果你打算自费，这可不是一笔小数目。但有些机构也会为员工提供资助，所以并不总是来自不同国家的人才需要自费，通过公司赞助也是可能的，这一点值得记住。所以大部分人会有在英国工作的权利，很可能已经是英国公民，并将申请由NHS资助的博士培训项目。所以我会在这个播客中主要提供这方面的建议，但如果你有超出这些的情况，那么，你知道，告诉我，或者，是的，去
Google. There's a lot that can be found on Google. So I'm aware that for the last few years, there has been a fee, an application fee for the clearinghouse. certainly of last year if you submit your application and pay before the 20th of October the fee was £30 but if you submit your application between the 21st of October and the deadline which last year was the 17th of November then the fee was £40 and they call it a processing fee. And the deadline time was 1pm on the 17th last year. But please do check the dates for 2022 because they may well be different. My advice would actually be consider whether your options and your experiences might be changing between the 21st of october and the 17th of november so if you're waiting for new job offer perhaps or to start a
谷歌搜索一下。谷歌上能找到很多信息。我知道过去几年，清算所是有申请费的。当然，去年如果你在10月20日之前提交申请并付款，费用是30英镑；但如果你在10月21日到截止日期（去年是11月17日）之间提交，费用就是40英镑，他们称之为处理费。去年截止时间是17日下午1点。但请务必核对2022年的日期，因为它们可能不同。我的建议是，考虑一下你的选择和经历是否会在10月21日到11月17日之间发生变化。如果你正在等待新的工作机会，或者即将开始一份
new job and there's something where you're waiting on publication details that you might be able to add to your dissemination section if there's something that might change between that first deadline time and the second that it's probably going to be in your interest to wait a little bit until you can put that on your form, because that might help you to score more points. But largely speaking, if you're confident that you are reflecting well, you've, you know, you've got enough experience that you've done a really good job on your form, or for that matter, if you're applying for a course where you just get invited to a selection test if you meet the criteria and so you're not so focused on the quality or the content of your form then you might
新工作，或者你在等待发表文章的细节，这些可以添加到你的传播部分。如果第一次截止时间和第二次之间有什么变化，那么等待一段时间直到你能把它写进表格可能对你更有利，因为这可能有助于你获得更多分数。但总的来说，如果你确信自己反思得很好，你有足够的经验，在表格上做得非常好，或者如果你申请的课程只要符合标准就会被邀请参加选拔测试，那么你就不必太关注表格的质量或内容，
well want to do it early so that it gets looked at early so that you get you know just I don't think you get any special treatment there are only so many places available for interview and you'll only get notified whether you've been invited for interview at the same time you know as everybody else which will be springtime which is a general order of events so usually sort of February March time dates come out for different courses and they're staggered. The interview dates are staggered. Usually they're around April, May, June time but they are quite well organized so that there shouldn't be too much overlap for courses that are geographically close. So it could well be that if you're applying for courses in different areas of
你可能很想早点提交，以便早点被审核。我不认为会有什么特殊待遇，面试名额有限，你只会和其他人同时收到是否被邀请面试的通知，那通常是在春季，这是大致的流程。通常在2月或3月左右，不同课程的日期会公布，而且是错开的。面试日期是错开的，通常在4月、5月、6月左右，但它们组织得很好，地理位置相近的课程应该不会有太多重叠。所以，如果你申请了不同地区的课程，
the country that you're getting invites in the same week it's not unheard of but there is usually some flexibility I don't even know if they maybe do a little bit of collaboration to make sure they're not offering you on the same day but if you were in a position where you did get offered on the same day I think it would be absolutely reasonable that they that they accommodate that change especially if it if it is an in-person interview so yeah should you wait is question one I think that really depends on your own circumstances. And if you have been, some people really like the summer to just like do nothing, psychology at all. Some people will have learned that they hadn't been successful during the 2022 season. They may have learned that in February, as early as February, March. And so it can feel like quite a wait from very early spring, late winter, to the very start of autumn on the 1st of September. So they might well have made a head start or perhaps even written their application already and so they may be eager and raring to go especially if they haven't got new
你可能会在同一周收到邀请，这并不罕见，但通常会有一些灵活性。我甚至不知道他们是否会进行一些协作，以确保不会安排在同一天。但如果你确实被安排在同一天，我认为要求他们调整是完全合理的，特别是如果是面对面面试的话。所以，是否应该等待是第一个问题，我认为这真的取决于你自己的情况。有些人真的很喜欢夏天什么都不做，完全不碰心理学。有些人可能在2022年申请季失败了，他们可能早在2月或3月就知道了结果。所以从早春、冬末到9月1日秋季开始，感觉会是很长的一段等待。所以他们可能已经提前准备，甚至已经写好了申请，所以他们可能迫不及待，特别是如果他们没有新的
experiences to pop on their form so I know when I was working as an assistant it could be fairly quick changing really you know in terms of the new opportunities and experiences that come up you know new groups that get offered to you to run or new research opportunities so for me I was also waiting on a job offer so I was able to put on my form that I was going to be starting a new job because I had a job start date then as well so by the time my form was reviewed I had actually started that job because I was due to start in the February so by the time I started by the time I did my interviews I'd already been working in that post for three-ish months so yeah it will be dependent on your unique factors you get to decide you get to choose there's no right
经历可以写在表格上的话。我知道我以前做助理的时候，机会和经历的变化可能很快，比如新提供的运行小组或新的研究机会。所以对我来说，我也在等工作录用通知，所以我能在表格上写明我即将开始一份新工作，因为那时我已经有了入职日期。所以当我的表格被审核时，我已经开始了那份工作，因为我预定在2月入职。所以当我面试时，我已经在那岗位上工作了大约三个月了。所以是的，这取决于你独特的因素，你可以决定，你可以选择，没有对
or wrong answer but it can be really useful to discuss that with your supervisor your clinical supervisor certainly if you are already being supervised by a qualified clinical psychologist to get a little bit of perspective a little bit of insight um also a really good idea to get someone qualified and also someone that's not anything to do with psychology to read your application form before you submit it because we want to be really sure that we're not using jargon so all the time when I've been screening forms and when I've looked at other people's forms and when I've even been reading and editing accounts for the upcoming aspiring psychologist book we can really heavily use jargon because we're so used to knowing what
或错的答案，但与你的主管、临床主管讨论一下会非常有用，特别是如果你已经由合格的临床心理学家督导，这能让你获得一点视角和洞察。另外，在提交申请表之前，找一个有资质的人，以及一个完全不懂心理学的人读一下你的申请表，也是一个非常好的主意，因为我们要确保没有使用行话。一直以来，当我筛选表格、看别人的表格，甚至在阅读和编辑即将出版的《有抱负的心理学家》一书的文稿时，我们可能会大量使用行话，因为我们太习惯于知道那意味着什么，或者只是使用缩写，这在我的特定领域或专业中可能意味着不同的东西，而对你来说可能意味着别的。所以，
that means or just using acronyms which might mean a different thing for me in my particular niche or specialty than it might mean for you so um sometimes we can't see our own jargon and it's only when someone who is not working in the area that you're working in says well what does that mean that you're like oh yeah okay i could perhaps do with not putting that um quite like that and explaining that a little bit more so So yeah, getting a little bit of advice about that is, so yeah, just getting some fresh eyes, some fresh perspective on your form can be a really good idea. And plus, because we often can't see our own typos. So getting some insider insight and reflection and opinion can be really useful. Let's just have a quick break here and I will be along to speak with you
有时我们看不出自己的行话，只有当一个不在你所在领域工作的人问“那是什么意思”时，你才会想“哦，是的，好吧，我可能不需要那样写，可以多解释一点”。所以，是的，获得一些关于这方面的建议，获得一些新的视角，对你的表格来说可能是一个非常好的主意。而且，因为我们经常看不出自己的错别字。所以获得一些内部洞察、反思和意见会非常有用。让我们在这里休息一下，稍后我会回来和你谈谈
about some more of my top tips on the other side. Hi, I'm Emily, an assistant psychologist from Surrey. I love being a part of the Aspiring Psychologist membership as Marianne and the group are really supportive and it has rekindled my love for psychology outside of work. I always look forward to Monday evenings when we have Zoom calls from different psychology specialists, such as CBT or cat therapists, as I always learn something new. I would recommend the Aspiring Psychologist membership to anyone who is feeling a little stuck on their psychology journey and can afford to invest in developing themselves outside of work so that is the first of our audio testimonials for the aspiring psychologist membership
我的一些其他顶级建议。嗨，我是Emily，来自萨里的助理心理学家。我很高兴能成为“有抱负的心理学家”会员的一员，因为Marianne和团队非常支持我，这重新点燃了我对工作之外心理学的热爱。我总是期待周一晚上的Zoom通话，会有不同的心理学专家，比如CBT或CAT治疗师，因为我总能学到新东西。我会向任何在心理学道路上感到有点困惑，并且有能力在工作之外投资于自我发展的人推荐“有抱负的心理学家”会员资格。这就是我们为“有抱负的心理学家”会员提供的第一条音频感言。
it really is a lovely place good things things are happening um and we do actually open for 15 more members on the 2nd of September as well so if you feel like adding some more compassion and some more hand-over-hand guidance and getting up close and personal with um qualified clinical psychologists from a variety of perspectives and also coming this September we have got a free mindfulness course happening as well for the members. We've also got lots of other well-being activities coming up, we've got a research clinic, we have got regular CBT teaching and we've got other disciplines as well to help really exacerbate, to help really bring on your formulation skills and your confidence in talking about considering and weighing up different options for treatment. So, yeah, it's exceptional value as well as just £30 a month for as long as you want to remain a member.
这确实是一个可爱的地方，好事正在发生。我们确实在9月2日又开放了15个会员名额。所以如果你想增加更多的同理心，获得更多的手把手指导，并与来自不同视角的合格临床心理学家近距离接触，而且今年9月我们还将为会员举办免费的正念课程。我们还有许多其他即将到来的健康活动，我们有研究诊所，有定期的CBT教学，还有其他学科，以真正帮助加深你的构思技巧，增强你讨论、考虑和权衡不同治疗方案的信心。所以，是的，每月只需30英镑，只要你想保持会员身份，这非常有价值。
So any price changes in future, if you are on board, will remain the same for you. Your price won't increase. So yeah, if you'd like any more information, have a look at the details on my website, which are in my show notes, or feel free to slip into my DMs as well. But the place is open at 8am on friday the 2nd of september but only if you're on the waiting list that's the only way you can get in so do sneak in and pop yourself on that waiting list and i'll see you there um it's all good stuff but i will always create free content for you um that is you know i firmly believe there should be qualified free access for anybody wanting to further their career in psychology and it shouldn't be like some big mystery okay so
所以未来任何价格变动，如果你已经在其中，对你来说将保持不变。你的价格不会上涨。所以，如果你想要更多信息，请查看我网站上的详细信息，它们在我的节目说明中，或者随时给我发私信。但名额在9月2日星期五上午8点开放，前提是你必须在候补名单上，这是进入的唯一途径。所以一定要悄悄把自己加到候补名单上，我会见到你的。这都是好东西，但我会一直为你创作免费内容，因为我坚信任何想要在心理学领域深造的人都应该有合格的免费获取途径，这不应该是什么大秘密。好了，
so my pledge to you is there will always be free content and it's probably a good time to just give you the dates for this year's compassionate Q&A to support the application process. The first one is on the day that I think it will be opening, which will be the 1st of September 2022. I will be streaming across my socials, but do come and join the Aspiring Psychologist community on Facebook if you're on Facebook. I will also be streaming across my other socials which are now pretty much all Dr Marianne Trent including YouTube so yeah wherever you like to hang out the only place it won't be streaming is TikTok because I can't stream via TikTok I don't think I've got enough followers yet but you could come and follow me on there um because there's other stuff that goes on there too um so yeah if you're a TikToker
所以我的承诺是，这里将永远有免费内容。现在可能是公布今年支持申请流程的“同理心问答”（Compassionate Q&A）日期的好时机。第一次是在我认为它开放的那天，也就是2022年9月1日。我将在我的社交媒体上进行直播，如果你在Facebook上，一定要加入“有抱负的心理学家”社区。我也会在我的其他社交媒体上直播，现在基本上都是Dr Marianne Trent，包括YouTube。所以，无论你喜欢在哪里闲逛，唯一不会直播的地方是TikTok，因为我不能通过TikTok直播，我想我还没有足够的粉丝，但你可以去那里关注我，因为那里也有其他内容。所以，如果你是TikTok用户，
is that a thing I think so um yeah I'm on there with Dr Marianne Trent anyway so the first one as I said is the 1st of September 2022 at 7 30 p.m and then the second one is the 10th of October also at 7 30 p.m they will be on my socials on those dates so the 1st of September and the 10th of October and there's also the replays that you can watch on my YouTube playlist as well so Dr Marianne Trent and you can find the playlist there as well if you can't make the lives but you'd like me to answer a question for you then feel free to get in contact with me via any of my socials and i will take a little screenshot and keep it in a special folder to be able to answer for you on any one of those dates and if you'd rather me not
这是个东西吗？我想是的。无论如何，我在那里叫Dr Marianne Trent。所以第一次直播正如我所说，是2022年9月1日晚上7点30分，第二次是10月10日晚上7点30分。它们会在这些日期的社交媒体上进行。所以是9月1日和10月10日，你也可以在我的YouTube播放列表中观看回放。搜索Dr Marianne Trent，如果你错过了直播，也可以在那里找到播放列表。如果你不能参加直播，但希望我为你回答问题，请随时通过我的任何社交媒体与我联系，我会截个图并保存在一个特殊的文件夹里，以便在任何一个日期为你解答。如果你不希望我
use your name do let me know that's okay too but obviously people have found them really useful in the past and it can just feel nice to be part of something this will be our third year I started doing these sessions for people across my socials in September 2020. And it's been lovely to be there for you, alongside you, with you, and also to grow with you. You know, first came the free Q&A's, then came the this podcast this very podcast then is coming imminently I've got lots and lots of work to do the aspiring psychologist collective book and if you'd like any information about when that's published you can jump on to the details in the show notes to register to be on the right mailing list for that.
使用你的名字，请告诉我，那也没问题。但显然人们过去觉得这些非常有帮助，成为其中一部分感觉很好。这将是我们第三年举办这些活动，我从2020年9月开始在社交媒体上为人们做这些环节。能为你、在你身边、与你在一起，并与你一起成长，真是太好了。你知道，首先是免费问答，然后是这个播客，这个播客本身，接下来即将到来的是——我还有很多很多工作要做——《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书。如果你想了解它何时出版，可以点击节目说明中的详细信息，注册加入正确的邮件列表。
So what can be useful when you are looking at getting a bit of you down on paper for your form? I think actually doing things on paper can be really useful, but also recording yourself speak can be really helpful because you get your own unique turns of phrase as well which can be really helpful so could you just like get over listening to the sound of your own voice trust me the more you do it the easier it gets and just start answering those questions aloud could that be really useful because the whole website's changing it might be that the whole process for applications is changing. HEE, Health Education England, threw us a bit of a curveball last year on the 1st of September, which was also the date of the publication of the ClinPsych Collective book, when they announced there were going to be funding changes for anybody that had had HEE funding for the last couple of years before.
那么，当你试图把自己的想法写在纸上时，什么是有用的呢？我认为把事情写在纸上真的很有用，但录下自己的讲话也很有帮助，因为你会得到自己独特的措辞，这也会非常有帮助。所以，你能克服听自己声音的尴尬吗？相信我，你做得越多，就越容易。只要开始大声回答那些问题，这真的很有用吗？因为整个网站都在变，可能整个申请流程也在变。英格兰健康教育局（HEE）去年9月1日给我们出了个难题，那天也是《临床心理学家集体》一书出版的日子，当时他们宣布，对于过去几年获得过HEE资助的任何人，资助政策将发生变化。
And they did it as a blanket policy at that point and said, you can't do that. You can't apply. You're no longer eligible. And there was lots of lobbying and surveys. And that was then later reversed largely through the work of Erkan, who calls himself Jason, his name is Erkan, and he did sterling work. So if you have indeed got a place on the clinical training this year, as indeed Erkan has, that is thanks to Erkan and to the people in his world that really helped, you know, lobby for that change. So if you wouldn't have been eligible, but you were able to apply them because of the rule change, you know, raise a little toast to him and the work that he did. He was not taking no for an answer. And I think he's i think he's very very inspiring commendable stuff
他们当时采取了一刀切的政策，说你不能这样做。你不能申请。你不再符合资格。当时有很多游说和调查。后来通过Erkan的工作，他自称Jason，他的名字是Erkan，他做了出色的工作，这项政策后来被撤销了。所以如果你今年确实获得了临床培训名额，正如Erkan所做的那样，那要感谢Erkan和他世界里那些真正帮助游说这一改变的人。所以如果你本来不符合资格，但因为规则改变而能够申请，那么，为他和他的工作举杯庆祝一下吧。他没有接受“不”作为答案。我认为他非常、非常鼓舞人心，值得称赞。
um so uh yeah well done to him and well done to you if you've got into training this year too and you might well be listening to this approaching starting your first few days and weeks as a trainee clinical psychologist that's what your badge is going to say um you know that's what your id card's going to say and it's a really amazing thing to see it printed for the first time first few times um you know catch yourself looking at it just thinking god that's me it's my photo on there it's really really good so um you know i also think it can be really useful to imagine that imagine you with that name badge around your neck your photo probably not the ideal photo you'd like mine was always a bit dodgy and bit grainy um not not a great hair day that day um imagine slightly less than ideal photo um or maybe you're knocking out the park and
嗯，所以，做得好，如果今年你也进入了培训，做得好。你可能正在听这个节目，准备开始作为临床心理学实习生的最初几天和几周。这就是你的徽章上会写的，你知道，这就是你的身份证上会写的。第一次看到它被印出来，真是太神奇了。你知道，你会发现自己看着它，心想“天哪，那是我，上面是我的照片”，这真的非常好。所以，你知道，我也认为想象一下很有用，想象一下你脖子上挂着那个写着你名字的徽章，照片可能不是你最理想的照片，我的总是有点奇怪，有点颗粒感，那天发型不太好，想象一下那张不太理想的照片，或者也许你表现得很好，
you're just like on point with your photos but mine would never great um just imagine your photo your name um and the title trainee clinical psychologist can you dare to imagine that what blocks come up for you does it make you cringe does it make you excited does it make you think oh it's never going to happen know, just explore and note down and work through any blocks that come up for you. Right. I've kind of waffled on and not said a super amount, I feel, but I hope it's been useful for you. I wanted to record an episode. The kids have gone out um for the afternoon um i'm also going to be live on berkshire radio bbc radio berkshire um this coming week as well it's going to be wednesday the 31st of august so if you have access to digital radio um even if you're not in berkshire
你的照片拍得很完美，但我的一直都不怎么样。只要想象一下你的照片、你的名字，以及“临床心理学实习生”这个头衔。你敢想象吗？你会有什么心理障碍？这会让你感到尴尬吗？还是让你兴奋？还是让你觉得“哦，这永远不会发生”？你知道，只要探索、记下并克服你出现的任何障碍。好了。我觉得我一直在唠叨，没说太多实质内容，但我希望这对你有用。我想录一期节目。孩子们下午出去了，我这周也会在伯克希尔电台（BBC Radio Berkshire）进行直播，那是8月31日星期三。所以如果你能收听数字广播，即使你不在伯克希尔，
please do tune into that um and they're going to be just talking to me about me. They want to talk about the podcast, which is really cool. So yeah, very, very nice to be contacted by them and invited onto there. So if you are local to Buckshire, or if you just want to listen to me waffling on a bit more, then do tune into that. I believe it's 12.30. And I hope hope you can listen to that on catch up and if you're already on my mailing list I will likely send a little um a little replay of that as well so if you don't want to miss out do head to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk if you scroll to the bottom you'll see the mailing list option and if whilst you're
也请一定要收听。他们会和我谈论我。他们想谈谈这个播客，这真的很酷。所以，是的，能被他们联系并邀请去那里真是太好了。所以如果你是伯克希尔本地人，或者如果你只是想听我多唠叨一会儿，那么一定要收听。我相信是12点30分。我希望你能通过回放收听。如果你已经在我的邮件列表中，我可能会发送一个回放链接。所以如果你不想错过，请前往我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，如果你滚动到底部，你会看到邮件列表选项。如果你在
there you fancied downloading my free supervision guide you absolutely could by just going to forward slash supervision at the end and then you can have that land in your inbox and there's been some really nice feedback about that as a free resource too so yeah i hope to catch up with you on this um first q a replays will be available across all of my socials um so the first of september at 7 30 p.m be there or be square and i'm just smiling to myself as i say that because i saw something on socials today that really made me laugh um it was a i think it was what probably a viral tweet um uh by a guy called rich neville so full full accountability there um and he'd posted this picture of some cheese bags um stay fresh cheese bags and with that he'd um put i found something new to say when i leave a room and it's just been making me laugh,
那里时想下载我的免费督导指南，你完全可以通过在末尾加上 /supervision 来实现，然后它就会发送到你的收件箱。作为免费资源，它也获得了一些非常好的反馈。所以，是的，我希望在第一次问答回放中见到你，它将在我所有的社交媒体上提供。所以9月1日晚上7点30分，不见不散。我一边说一边对自己微笑，因为我今天在社交媒体上看到了一些让我大笑的东西。我想那可能是一条病毒式传播的推文，由一个叫Rich Neville的人发的，所以完全归功于他。他发了一张奶酪袋的照片，写着“保持新鲜的奶酪袋”，他写道“我发现了一个离开房间时说的新话”，这让我一直笑，
just as even as I say it to myself, stay fresh cheese bags. Oh, so yeah, could I make that my new sign off rather than thanks for being part of my world? Stay fresh cheese bags. Probably not. I might stick with my more compassionate approach. But yeah, if you want to adopt stay fresh cheese bags please do so thanks to rich neville whoever you are for bringing that to my ears and my consciousness right be kind to yourself enjoy this bank holiday if you are indeed listening on the monday of your if you're listening um on catch-up replay it's all all fresh, it's all good, then I hope you had a good bank holiday. And I'm fully aware, not everyone gets bank holidays off as well. Many of us have to work when we're in supporting roles. So if you've been doing that, then I hope you
即使我对自己说，保持新鲜的奶酪袋。哦，所以，我能把它作为我的新结束语，而不是“感谢成为我世界的一部分”吗？保持新鲜的奶酪袋。可能不行。我可能会坚持我更具同理心的方法。但如果你想采用“保持新鲜的奶酪袋”，请随意。感谢Rich Neville，无论你是谁，把这个带到了我的耳朵和意识里。好了，善待自己，如果你确实是在周一收听，享受这个银行假日吧。如果你是在回放中收听，一切都很新鲜，一切都很好，那么我希望你度过了一个愉快的银行假日。我也完全意识到，并不是每个人都能在银行假日休息。我们很多人在支持岗位上工作时必须工作。所以如果你一直在这样做，那么我希望你
enjoy your day off, hopefully in lieu at a later stage. So yeah, I will see you very soon. Get to see my face as well, which is good. I will be available on the Q&A, the Compassionate Q&A, 1st of September. So until then, thanks for being part of my world. And I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode, if not before. Take care. Then let this be your guide With this podcast I feel sad You're beyond your weight to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical
享受你的休息日，希望以后能补休。所以，是的，我们很快就会再见。也能见到我的脸，这很好。我将在9月1日的“同理心问答”中出现。在那之前，感谢成为我世界的一部分。我期待在下一期节目中与你相见，如果不是之前的话。保重。让这成为你的指南，有了这个播客，我感到难过，你离获得资格还有很长的路要走。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康实习生。我读了《临床
psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。